wie sie alle wissen hat das team unserer
virologie der sind gerade kurz
vorgestellt hat wurde schon im frühjahr
des vergangenen jahres mit großer
tatkräftiger unterstützung der
bevölkerung als ich dort eine sehr
private studie durchgeführt um
festzustellen wie hoch die antikörper
belastung in ist ließ und wie viele
menschen dort möglicherweise erkrankt
waren und später auch eine immunität
aufgebaut haben wir haben damals schon
mit wir meine ich natürlich die
kolleginnen aus dem bereich der biologie
mit dort den behörden und den
entscheidungsträgern diskutiert dass es
wohl eine ausgezeichnete idee wäre wenn
wir die möglichkeit hätten gesellten
menschen auch nach zu verfolgen um der
ganz entscheidenden frage nachzugehen
wie lange eine immunität nach einer saß
co2 infektion auch bestimmt bleibt das
war zu dieser zeit noch völlig unklar
und es gab ganz ganz wenige daten es
gibt im übrigen auch heute noch bis auf
unsere studie ganz ganz wenige daten aus
großen repräsentativen studien in diese
richtung insofern haben wir rasch
zuspruch erhalten von den
verantwortlichen dort die dazu geführt
haben dass wir heuer im november eben
die entsprechende nach untersuchung
durchgeführt haben das projektteam wurde
diesmal von corinna geleitet die mit der
kollegin von laer am institut für
virologie in unserer medizinischen
universität seit vielen vielen jahren
biologisch in höchst erfolgreichen masse
tätig ist
wer also diese untersuchung primär
deswegen gestartet um festzuhalten
wie viele von den menschen die damals
positive antikörpertiter hatten die auch
jetzt noch haben und zusätzlich hat uns
noch weiters interessiert wie insgesamt
die immunität also über die reinen
antikörper aus zum beispiel dass
t-zellen anbelangt die kinder zählen und
ähnliche geologische parameter nach
dieser nach beobachtung frist von ja
über acht monaten sich darstellen würde
die daten die sie gleich wären werden
von den beiden kolleginnen vorgestellt
finde ich
nicht nur wissenschaftlich im höchsten
masse interessant spannend und innovativ
sondern auch und daher beim subtexte
news aus ist sehr ermutigend sie werden
details gleich hören
ich glaube das ist ganz wichtig ist dass
in dieser zeit wo viele diskussionen
durch immens starke emotionen getragen
sind in dieser ganzen diskussion wenn
aus der wissenschaftlichen seite hier
fakten präsentiert werden daten
präsentiert werden die dann als
grundlage dienen können für weitere
überlegungen das ist auch der aufbau
unsere unserer kurzen zusammenfassung
sie werden zuerst von der kollegin
corinna die datenlage vorgestellt
bekommen und dann nachher von kollegen
von la ein bisschen diese daten im
kontext diskutiert wissen welche
emotionen erwähnt habe sind emotionen
natürlich prinzipiell nichts ungünstiges
nur in einer heißen diskussion wie sie
zurzeit geführt wird war die emotionen
vielleicht ein bisschen mehr von ärger
und anderen dinge getragen als von
wissenschaftlicher neugier de
ich hätte gerne die diskussion wieder
auf diese wissenschaftliche neugierde
zurückgeführt und das in dem zusammen
auch eine bitte an sie äußern wir wissen
dass die diskussion auch politisch sehr
hoch gekocht ist in der letzten zeit
möchte daran erinnern dass unsere
aufgabe als universität berlin mehr eine
wissenschaftliche aufgabe ist dass wir
uns bemühen daten zu liefern grundlagen
zu liefern die es dann
entscheidungsträgerinnen auch auf der
politischen seite möglich machen daraus
bestimmte konsequenzen abzuleiten und
insofern würde ich sie sehr bitten dass
wir wirklich die diskussion nach danach
und die fragen die sie stellen sich
primär auf die forschung konzentrieren
was dann damit geschieht in letzter
konsequenz ist nicht unsere medizinische
aufgaben auch die und wartung sondern es
müssen andere entscheidungsträger dann
bestimmen die ich im übrigen nicht
beneide um diese funktion soll an dieser
stelle auch angemerkt werden im frühjahr
2020 gibt es ins spiel eine große welle
an kuwait 19 infektionen um
herauszufinden wie viele personen gegen
kurve die immun sind ist
eine studie durchgeführt worden jetzt
gibt es eine folgestudie um nachzuweisen
ob die immunität der bevölkerung immer
noch vorhanden ist
da es im sommer wenig fälle in der
ortschaft gegeben hat erwartet man ein
gutes ergebnis wie im frühjahr in ischgl
haben wir uns die antikörper sehr genau
angeschaut
also den humorale namen der bunten
antwort antikörper die an das virus
bitten und damit das virus inaktivieren
es kann also nicht mehr andere
infizieren nicht nur antikörper schützen
vor dem virus sondern auch die
sogenannten t-zellen sie befinden sich
bereits in unserem körper t zellen haben
eine andere funktion als antikörper t
zellen erkennen zellen im körper die
infiziert worden sind zum beispiel in
der lunge in der nase im rachen und
bevor diese zelle so richtig virus
machen kann bringen diese t-zellen diese
so genannten killer t zellen
diese infizierten zellen um so dass die
virus produktion im körper effizient
unterdrückt wird also die antikörper die
das virus selbst in aktiviert und die
t-zellen die killer t zellen die
infizierte zellen gleich abräumen
kontrollieren gemeinsam die
virusinfektion im infizierten in der
ersten novemberwoche nimmt die
medizinische universität innsbruck dann
den einwohnern von ischgl auf
freiwilliger basis blut ab über 800
personen haben mitgemacht das blut ist
zuerst auf antikörper und dann auf t
zellen untersucht worden
zur analyse ob die täter nun stimuliert
sind gibt es ja zwei verfahren das alles
bot verfahren und das faktorverfahren
da ist er es bot verfahren macht die
aktivierung der zellen optisch sichtbar
durch punkte in einem mikrotiterplatten
das lässt sich aber natürlich nicht
quantifizieren wir wissen auch nicht
welche zellen das genau sind die das
stimuliert sind um das genauer
anzuschauen brauchen wir die sogenannte
durchflusszytometrie die misst genau für
jede zelle wie stark sie aktiviert ist
und auch was es für ein typ von celle
ist die studie erlaubt den
wissenschaftlern in einer fixen
population den verlauf der immunität zu
beobachten
forschen leer
dieser beitrag wurde ihnen präsentiert
von der medizinischen universität
innsbruck
wie bereits erwähnt wurde im april in
ischgl ein sehr hoher serie prävalenz
festgestellt was bedeutet hohe prävalenz
das heißt einfach vieler personen
infektion durchgemacht haben
eine zentrale frage daraus ist dann wie
lang dieser antikörper dieser immunität
jetzt circa sechs monate nach der erste
nach dem ersten iphone bzw bis zu acht
monate nach der ersten infektionen wie
lang diese antikörper nachweisbarkeit
bleibt und noch eine weitere frage ist
welche auswirkungen hat dieser damals
hohe privat uns auf die weiteren
übertragungen
um dieser frage so beantworten führten
wir anfangen eine folgestudie nach der
zustimmung der ethikkommission der
medizinischen universität innsbruck
haben wir alle bewohner erwachsenen
bewohner studio eingeladen
die teilnahme war weiterhin sehr groß
insgesamt sind 900 knapp über 900
personen zu studie erschienen 801 davon
waren personen die auch bei der ersten
studie mitgemacht haben sehr interessant
ist auch die tatsache dass personen oder
die jene teilnehmer die bei der ersten
studie positiv waren reh ausweichen
studie gekommen sind als die personen
die negativ waren
was haben wir genau gemacht in ischgl
zum einen haben wir
mittels fragebögen ausführliche daten
erhoben so langfristigen auswirkungen
gesundheitliche auswirkungen der baskets
war infektionen beziehungsweise die die
strengen präventionsmaßnahmen
dieser teil der studie ist noch in
bearbeitung und wird zum späteren zeit
kommuniziert wir haben auch bei aller
studienteilnehmer blut abgenommen um die
antikörper test durchzuführen und bei
einer ausgewählte kleine population der
studienteilnehmer wurden etwas mehr
volumen blut abgenommen für die
zelluläre oder die täter untersuchung
was haben wir im labor gemacht zum einen
die antikörper untersuchung für die
antikörper untersuchung haben die
mehrere testverfahren eingesetzt einfach
damit unser ergebnisse valider sind
spezifisch und einfach die aussagekraft
gesichert ist und das heißt wir haben
antikörper untersucht die an
verschiedene viraler strukturen
gerichtet sind
zusätzlich haben wir die sogenannten
neutralisierende antikörper untersucht
also die sind die jene antikörper die
gezielt an der stelle der des beraten
protein binden die dann wichtig sind für
virale eintritt in die zellen dh die
neutralisierende antikörper verhindern
infektion wie bereits erwähnt haben wir
auch bei einem ausgewählten population
gruppe von personen haben wir die
zelluläre immunität untersucht spricht
die immunantwort oder ein teil der
immunantwort die unterstützend zu humor
aalen oder antikörper basierten antwort
funktioniert aber teilweise auch
unabhängig von antikörper antwort
separat
verläuft dabei haben wir die immunzellen
spricht die weiße blutkörperchen aus dem
blutprobe isoliert und mit verschiedenen
bestandteile des virus in kopiert oder
kultur irrt im mund zählen die einmal
mit dem in der vergangenheit mit dem
virus in kontakt gekommen sind erkennen
dieser bestandteile und demnach
produzieren substanzen zu geben signale
und dieser signal können wir dann auch
sichtbar machen und im labor messen ja
jetzt fragt sich jeder was ist aus
unserer studie geworden was sind die
ergebnisse ich erwähne nur die
kernergebnisse bevor weitergibt
bezugnehmend auf unserer
studienteilnehmer die aktuell im
november so studie gekommen sind sind 45
prozent weiterhin positiv auf antikörper
von von den personen die damals bei der
ersten studie
dabei waren und zweiter studie gekommen
sind 90 prozent haben weiterhin
antikörper und aus denen bei denen wie
die zelluläre immunität untersucht haben
sieht gibt's hinweis auf 70 prozent dass
sie auch zelluläre immunität haben wir
haben gesehen fast bei jedem
studienteilnehmer die damals positiv
waren die antikörper konzentration ab
sinkt aber die antikörper sind
qualitativ viel besser sie binden
stärker an ihren geschickten ziel
proteine und die sind großenteils
neutralisiert und dann noch die frage
was war die auswirkung dieser
hohe prävalenz ob wir jetzt neue
infektionen gesehen haben oder nicht nur
anhand unserer antikörper untersuchungen
haben wir gesehen dass von den personen
die damals gezielt gesichert kein
antikörper hatten sie nur ein prozent
oder weniger die jetzt neu antikörper
entwickelt haben